[Music]
I have found I've stumbled across
something and look maybe maybe I'm wrong
maybe I'm not but you know sometimes
when you feel like something is being
pushed artificially by the DNC or
there's like somebody you're like some
stuff about something a certain YouTube
channel seems like it's not right
um well I I came across this guy okay I
don't know if any of you guys know him
and this is the litmus test obviously to
know if you guys know him
um does anybody know who this guy is
right now that's on the show not that I
know okay does anybody not because I
wanted this is anybody in either of the
chats know who this guy is without me
telling you who he is and there's I do
want to say I already don't trust this
guy this guy's full of [ __ ] because he's
not really in space
he's not I don't think so anyway we
really are in space in ours
um
who no no no Stone Cold Steve it's not
Stone Cold Steve Austin no no no no no
no guys okay that's not Ethan Ralph's
brother no so
this guy this is called the ring of fire
it's a verified account it has 864
000 subscribers now you're talking about
someone that
should have crossed our purview at some
point right has not yeah um he's totally
Lefty I'm gonna play with just a little
clip of his latest video so you kind of
understand uh what he's about according
to a former staffer for also 800 000
views that's the my quality sorry
continue Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
who spoke with Gabe Sherman of fairing
cousins
look what his name is on Twitter at
farrenbalanced
oh my God I've seen that Twitter before
and I I've been like okay so maybe maybe
we maybe this guy is one of those I've
seen no I've seen him like replying to
somebody on Twitter he's probably
boosted artificially on there too that's
what I'm saying that's what I'm starting
to feel like with this guy and I'm going
to show you my my reasons why
uh fair and balance host of Ring of Fire
44 000 Subs okay anyway
the Vanity Fair of course didn't reveal
his name but a former staffer of
Governor Ron DeSantis says that DeSantis
routinely and repeatedly trashes Donald
Trump but by the way I I love that look
we're a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] that
make jokes about dead [ __ ] grieving
mothers teeth and [ __ ] we're not
pretending we're nice people or good
people but that being said
I'll be I'm a good guy Papa even us
a person wouldn't be like a former
staffer of Joe Biden says that he kills
dogs I'd be like that guy's probably
lying because he's mad you know it's
like but no it's like a former staffer
of DeSantis who probably got fired for
like stealing office supplies is now
talking [ __ ] about him behind the scenes
at one point what's his name
guy who still wears Dockers shirts
yeah well let me read the guy who
doesn't even like see the fact that the
shirt's not a good pattern bro this
shirt is easy and then you just wore it
anyway this shirt is a terrible pattern
for what he's doing this quote from this
former staffer
he calls him a TV personality and a
[ __ ] who has no business running for
president DeSantis says the only way to
beat Trump is to attack him head on
never said it he's never said that he's
never shown that he's never by the way
he may even think to Trump's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but he's a smart enough guy
to not be like mouthing off in front of
a bunch of staffers you know who he who
we tell that to his wife his wife that's
it exactly any smart politician would
tell his wife in that and I guarantee
you he probably has laid next to his
wife at night and gone God sometimes I
wish I could just shut his [ __ ] mouth
right but he never he never afforded
attacking him head on yeah he's not
sitting in a [ __ ] lunchroom on a
lunch break in his office with six other
people going big orange [ __ ] yeah
you're right
about him being a [ __ ] who has no
business running for president if that
is what Ron DeSantis hey what are your
qualifications here a big guy what is
that the last guy who wears Docker
shirts guy that is in Santa chroma key
works or a guy who you bought the
cheapest lapel mic on Amazon like what's
your thing I'm trying to figure out what
it is maybe I don't know what it is
maybe I'm new to you by the way I don't
know who you are but are you just one of
these other people that like the oh boy
oh boy guy are you one of those guys are
you one of those guys that just pops up
into this basic [ __ ] Boomer talking
points because here's the thing on this
show you can look it up we've made fun
of a lot of right-wing grifters too we
remember [ __ ] Dilly's a great example
Brendan Dilly a great example but
I kind of feel that we've let a lot of
these lefties go I think we've kind of
left them be out there and and do their
little thing you're the same thing y'all
you do all your little show is guy who
[ __ ] Alex Rosen should sue for
stealing his face what you should do is
no I'm [ __ ] he looks like the meme of
that guy you know the the meme of like
the the old Spanish guy yes one that
always looks uneasy yeah yeah the the
internet historian uses it as his uh
yeah picture yeah
saying behind closed doors then Ron
DeSantis is telling the truth
for once
what I have an issue with is audio
quality chroma keys
being likable being interesting coming
up with points of views that are that
you're not just reading from DNC talking
points or seeing what Don Lemon said the
night before and then repeating it I
mean is that what your thing is because
I'm really trying to understand what
valuable service you provide to the left
wing movement DeSantis says the only way
to beat Trump is to attack him head on
that's why he's trashing him behind
closed doors where nobody can hear it
right you know he he has built an entire
narrative him something you can't prove
hearsay he built an entire narrative on
a playing telephone
no you know where these guys started
this guy started with Sam seder oh over
on it air America there it is remember
air America I remember Al franken's air
America
I remember air America
good company because that you know
you're doing good air America's doing
really good it's really great you're on
YouTube now and by the way artificial
can I explain why Marsh
864 000 subscribers right we know that
that's fine
we have 44 almost 45 000 right
just as a comparison
um
he has a patreon
how many patrons do you think a show
that has 860 000 people should have
almost 10 000 of those people should at
least be that's that's a good membership
that's a good conversion that is a very
very good conversion unfortunately it
has 282.
patrons so this is all so all these
numbers are [ __ ] these are all
[ __ ] for five dollars a month you
get weekly access to exclusive videos
what we do basically and plus all
previous rewards which are early acts of
the week in videos plus our previous
rewards Patron only polls so you're
telling me that you only have 282 people
we have 44 000 people we have on an
average month about 17 100 people give
or take
um on our patreon so
I really feel like this is another
artificially push immersion now that you
told me used to be air America
one because those are those are the same
people that work with YouTube that you
YouTube was the YouTube was basically
The Fallout Shelter after air America
failed that's where they all came like
you said Sam Sater and [ __ ] they all
came over here they all came over to
YouTube this is artificial [ __ ]
you're just by the way you have a fair
and balance you [ __ ] is that all you do
just repeat talking points because it
seems pretty [ __ ] stupid bro that's
not true it just makes them up out of
thin air oh good point a big strong
tough guy DeSantis never pretended to be
a big strong tough guy
yeah we're gonna take this guy head on
by the
by the way again this is let me tell you
something
watch your head watch this but watch
this but watch this because I'm gonna
now see because if we're gonna we'll be
playing with a little Ron DeSantis
action figure
but by the way since we're doing this
check this out watch what I'm gonna do
because I could do this now there's no
reason he just did it let me tell you
something
a former staffer of Sam seder told me
that farron cousins
used to confide in him that he'd like to
go and smell the koala change stations
at every Applebees he'd go and he'd
sniff it and he goes I'd like to see
where I'd like to see where that juice
is made is what he would say I don't
again that is look I can't confirm it I
can't give up my source I'm just saying
that somebody that told me that they
used to work for him says that farron
cousins likes to sniff koala uh koala
care changing stations and unfortunately
as a journalist I cannot reveal my
source can't reveal your Source but
that's the the scuttlebutt is that a
former staffer and and the stuff about
paying homeless men to urinate on them
that stuff was just weird was out of
control this guy was like yummy yummy
yummy I don't know if he did this this
is this is just the rumor that I hear
around that I didn't even say who I was
talking about I might have been talking
about the former staffer there I left it
very vague that's a very that's a very
good point let's just say this there's a
former air America employee these are
like the dirt sheets by the way way who
is bald and has a beard and wears shirts
and you can't chroma key I won't say who
he is and may enjoy a little bit of
homeless urine once right because he
says it tastes like popcorn that is what
somebody like really salty popcorn that
is what somebody that used to be on the
staff
of air America told us about a certain
person
on YouTube
Jesus Christ man I don't know if it's
true I don't know if it's true again but
can you imagine if you're that guy
that's crazy what a bunch of sickos if
that's true if that's true we don't know
if that's true that could be completely
made up
but again let's do an entire five-minute
segment on it oh wait we already have
microwave or movie theater
movie theater popcorn
nice guess what extra butter
the good stuff
so uh the the ring of fire podcast I'm
just looking at numbers is it good is it
real good is it blown up numbers
they have a website he has a website the
Ring of fires and gay stupid [ __ ]
website all right for for a guy who runs
a show that has [ __ ] over 800k subs
what do you think his number should look
like on the website you know like total
visits bounce rate [ __ ] like that you
know just just get that in your head
what you think it should be
his total visits are only 15K
yeah no there's something going on his
bounce rate is 81.9 uh nine seven
percent with pages per visit on average
being 1.2 and an average visit duration
of two seconds
that means the only people going to his
website are [ __ ] Google crawlers now
look here's and you're right and and and
and and here's the thing and this is
what I heard by the way Virgie from from
an inside source that a certain person
who was bald and has a beard that used
to work for air America uh not only uses
Google crawlers but he likes to smell
where actual babies crawled over which
is again weird
I don't know why they told me that it
might be a lie and look listen I hope it
is
I hope it is
see that's the problem uh by the way uh
faren when you start using blind items
and dirt sheets and all this [ __ ] is
that then people start doing it to you
and then nothing's true anymore
everything is just a [ __ ] rumor the
telephone plate come on man
and now again I can't reveal who who
told me all this information but it's
out there you know it's out there now it
is it is sale if you're thinking here's
another tip off his [ __ ] views on his
videos are wildly inconsistent yeah I
saw that too
like
100k 47k 5K like what the [ __ ] is yo
this dude's sketch as [ __ ] look all I'm
saying is if that if people
want to ask at Farren f a r r o n
balanced one word on Twitter what these
blind items are about we can't stop you
that's for sure
say it right right if you think this guy
has no business running for president
because he's a washed up Yahoo don't be
afraid I don't think anybody even if
even if the blind item is true did
anybody say washed up Yahoo by the way
who the [ __ ] says washed up Yahoo oh I
know who a washed up Yahoo
I know but we'll never know because I
promise you something right now
this is another of the what I call this
this The Young Turks was the first
people on YouTube that experienced this
this artificial push but there's a lot
of them now that are getting this
artificial push you know
it
what's he gonna do get on Truth social
make fun of you and five people are
gonna see it
like you're on Twitter Ron you've got
millions of followers
you've got the bigger microphone a large
percentage of his followers
also like Trump so you want him to just
start a fight with Trump for no reason
no no but this guy's an idiot bro this
listen that's the one thing you know
about this guy this guy's an idiot this
guy repeats whatever the talking points
he's given every more you could see it
by the way you can see it look this guy
wouldn't last three seconds on this show
merch I think we don't know that right
like he'd fall apart immediately number
one of course because he takes himself
too seriously that's number one
uh number two he's a buffoon he's doing
he's a [ __ ] buffoon and he's
pretending himself we're buffoons and we
present ourselves as buffoons he is
buffoon and he's presenting himself like
I don't know like what Mark Harley does
you know
oh okay fair and balance let's see what
you got big boy
um